hello gray Otis cristela here from Who
Wants to Be a Millionaire
so first up let's play who wants to be
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry it's had too much time in lock
down your TV radio presenter right we're
doubly stably about their record so how
many sadhus did william shakespeare
right now that's audits got planes
Saudis have any solids did we feel right
is it a sixty to be eighty four shakes
I'm not very good on Shakespeare is
there any chance can I use my phone
afraid you got your life like you've got
your life let's grab you've got your ask
the audience which I wouldn't try I'm
not gonna pass the audience you go
you're fifty fifty do I'll phone a
friend now people who know Shakespeare
how we've either got Ian McKellen or
Judi Dench I'm going with Judi Dench
here we go
[Music]
hello judi dench how it's Graham Norton
here and how are you coping
judi dench okay well what I'm doing for
no good reason is playing Who Wants to
Be a Millionaire
so I've got a question here's the
question so the question is how many
sonnets did Shakespeare writes how many
of you learned so you are certainly 154
alright thank you so much Judy oh thank
you so much I good luck to you in the in
the restful doctor and we'll see you in
the flesh
very soon I hope all right much love
bye bye bye okay she sounds very
confident so I am going to go with D 154
that's the answer you go for good
yes for a billion pounds it's the
correct answer well done
[Music]
you